despite being devastated by a powerful
earthquake in 2013 these century-old
churches remained a top tourist
destination until the pandemic broke out
the months-long lockdown and the closing
of international borders to visitors
devastated the tourism industry here for
months leaving thousands unemployed
just as the visayas province was slowly
recovering last year typhoon ride
destroyed many parts in december
who works on a tourist boat says the
lack of visitors was just too much
it was like you were happy the other day
and the next day you're sad because you
might not have a job the next day
how could they pay my expenses so when
we started operating again even though
we only had two customers it felt like
we were already back
people say visiting behalf is synonymous
with seeing the entire country the
province is rich with biodiversity and
steep in history this is why it's long
been called the heart of the philippine
islands
the tourism industry accounts for nearly
12 percent of gdp so the government's
decision to reopen the country to
international travelers again as kovid
cases decrease significantly is giving
many here a renewed sense of hope and
purpose
the impact is so positive because you're
talking about the drivers the porters
the the tour operators we're looking at
a great multiplier effect and that also
reverberates to agriculture that
reverberates to fisheries because all of
that influx of visitors contributes to a
volume of need
earthquakes a super typhoon and the
pandemic the litany of tragedies may
seem unbearable
but the roman catholic church has always
served as a moral and spiritual compass
for communities here
and so in times of hardship the faithful
say prayers to god and know that somehow
there will be a better way
jamilah linda al-jazeera bohol province
central philippines